bon bah merci
alors est ce que vous pourriez même prix
mais deux attestations surtout pas
oublier bien sûr je vous en prie aime ça
tout de suite a alors un congé plus
d'encre tu désolé c'est pas grave
ah bon parce que petite fille il existe
trois héros parce que petite fille le
monde est tellement beau ils sont sûrs
bleu jaune jaune bleu rouge
ils sont rouges et jaunes et jaune et
bleu ils viennent pour les jours heureux
ils vont mal 4 et pourtant sans trois
tout le monde alors nous on bouge ton
corps et ton joie car ils viennent eux
mêmes
être une cartouche vas-y ouvre le clapet
il arrive là je fais thierry vas-y ah
oui d'accord
après des gens
c'est bon
caillé